غضب غضب واسع في السودان والسعوديه سبب
مقلب على مواقع التواصل كان مقصده كوميديا
لكنه تحول لازمه وجد الاجتماعي المقلب
مشاهدينا الذي اثار الجدل اضر برجل سوداني
وبعائلته بعد انتشاره على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي النيابه العامه السعوديه قررت
حبسه شابين المتسببين بالمقلب بتهمه
الاساءه للاداب العامه
وحرمه الحياه الخاصه مؤكده النيابه تحريك
دعوا قضائيه ضد شابين
مع الرجل السوداني ضحيه المقلب الذي اكد
ان الفيديو المنتشر شو
ه سم خرب بيته على حد تعبيره
يلا توكل على الله
يلا انزل
وقعنا في الكمين انزلوني
انت شوف الكاميرا شوف الكاميرا قدامك
الكاميرا قدامك
طيب ابشر ابشر
هذا بتاع المقلب اقسم بالله واقف في
الشارع على عيالي
[موسيقى]
عنده عمل وجاني وطبق فوق المنظر والله ما
اعرف حاجه انا انسان امي وهذا التلفون
والله
ما كان عندي تلفون وسع ما اعرف عليه ولا
اعرف اكتب ولا اعرف اقرا ما اعرف اي حاجه
والله انسان وقاعد وجاي وطلب الرزق لعيالي
والله طبا فوق منظر خسر علي الدنيا كلها
وخسر علي البيت هناك مع عيال اخواني الحين
حتى اولاد اقسم بالله خلق لي معاهم مشكله
ما اقدر اكلمهم في التلفون
طيب
المخادع الظريف هذا اللقب حمله ضيفنا
اليوم لعده سنوات بعد ان نجح في تقديم
الكثير من المقالب المميزه دون ان تكون
مؤذيه
طيب اعيش وكل غيرها او غيرها زي
اللبناني تعيش وتاكل غيرها يعني كان احد
ابرز ما قدمه كميل الاسمر الذ تنبيه طبعا
كل ذلك كان لانه يتميز بحسه الفكاهي
ومقالبه التي طالما كانت محببا للجماهير
في لبنان وفي الوطن العربي قدم كميل
الاسمر العديد من البرامج الخاصه بالمقالب
ولعل اشهرها كل شافوك الذي حمل جرعه مميزه
من المقالب المثيره
للضحك وعلى مدى ثلاثين عاما حظي كميل
الاسمر بمتابعه كبيره على العديد من طبعا
او في كثير من المنازل التي دخلها منازل
اللبنانيين والعرب ليرسم الضحكه على
وجوههم
هلا بدنا نعلي الدوز قلت له
يلا يلا
[موسيقى]
هيدا مين مين
اللي بالمقلب لانه في ناس تعصب طيب من
بيروت ينضم الينا احد رواد المقالب
بالتلفزيونيه الكوميديه الكوميديه للاسمر
وابنا فراس الاسمر يسعد صباحكم
صباح الخير يا صباح الورد مين مين عاشوا
اكل غيره ههه
خلينا نبدا شوي بعيدا عن الفكاهه ونحكي
شوي جد دقيقه وبعدين بنرجع للمقالب وين
المسموح وين الممنوع بالمقالب لوين بتوقف
وين الخط الاحمر
توقف عند الكرامات
وعندنا الشخص جسديا
وما فيك تحكي اللي بدك اياه
وفي شعره كتير بسيطه يعني
احنا بنقول له للتحيه قول باي للكاميرا
معناتها هو راضي مش معناته
نفس الشيء عند فراس هيدي هيدي الحدود ولا
بتختلف
مضبوط
بكلام الناس نحن هذا الفكره
ما نضحك على الناس طيب
يعني اكيد اكيد انه من غير المسموح انك
تهين اي شخص او تمس كرامته ولكن في ناس
ممكن ما بيشوفوا انه هذا المقلب بمس
الكرامه او بهين بينما غيرهم عندهم رقيق
اخر يعني ما في تعريف
يمكن محدد مسؤولي شو اللي ممكن يمس
لا لازم بده يلعب هاللعبه هلا انا ما بقدر
حالي من وراه واعمل حالي
وين بدها توصل
نفس نفس الشيء ولا السوشيال ميديا بيختلف
ولا لانه كميل خلص ختيار وعلى التي في وما
في يكون يكون الا بهذا الجو مثلا عنه شباب
وين راح
نحنا على فكره طالعين عنا تصوير اليوم
فنحن على الطريق
انه هل لانه على تي في هاي الخطوط الحمراء
ولا السوشيال ميديا بتختلف
خطوط حمراء اكثر من السوشيال ميديا بس
كمان هذا الشيء ما بيعني لازم النظر اليوم
كرامه ضحيه انا ما بحب اقول ضحيه يعني
كريم رامي شخص عم يشتغل معه هي قبل
كرامتنا ممنوع نضحك على حدا نحن لازم نضحك
نحن والشخص اللي عم نعمل مقلب وفي شعرك
بين الضرب والمقلب هيدا بيعرف بس وما هيك
وما هيك
فراس حتى مع وجود هذه الشعره والحد الفاصل
الا انه في ناس كثير ممكن انها تنزعج
وتعصب بشكل كبير رغم انه انت ما تعديتش
الحدود حدود الادب والاخلاق
يعني اللي عم نحكي عنها طيب
بالنهايه اليوم نحن عم نعمل مقلب مش ضرب
ضرب هو عباره عن خوف واكس نحن بنحب
المقالب المقالب هي عباره عن ضحك بغض
النظر اكيد بده يكون في زعل وتعصيب الحلقه
بطريقه مهضومه بس ما بنرضع
بس يقول الكاميرا هو بمجرد كانه موديله ان
هو موافق ومنه زعلان طيب يعني يبدو انه
كبير فهل لانه زعل من كلمه ختيار وما تحمل
المقلب طول عمره بيعمل مقالب لا نحن عم
نمزح بالتاكيد فراس يعني كل الاحترام
والتقدير لالك ولا اله وبالتاكيد احنا
عارفين انه في خطوط حمراء انتم بتوقفوا
عندها وما بتروحوا اكثر لتاذوا يعني
الاخرين ومشاعرهم شكرا جزيلا لك فراس
وشكرا لكميل الاسمر وكل الحب والتقدير
موفقين بالتصوير لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات